- [Kelly] So, Benedict W, sorry.
- Hey.
- I heard that you lie to DJ on set.
Is this true, and what's
your favorite music?
- I do like to DJ.
If you need to employ me,
it's DJ Obi Wong...Can You Feel The Force.
- Did you say DJ Obi Wong?
(crowd laughs and applauds)
That's amazing
- True story, I thought people shorten it
to just DJ Obi Wong.
- Yeah.
- So we...
- 10 outta 10.
- We share a make-up trailer, don't we?
So, we always kind of
putting the tunes out there.
- Almost every morning,
we would like play really-
- What kind of hype music
are you listening to?
It's not Joni Mitchel,
- [Xochitl] We play Rave music
so, what are we listening to?
- also, lots of Lizzo.
- [Kelly] Ooh, I like it.
- Olivia Rodrigo, of course.
- Love the whole record.
- Well, she's always trying to pull me
into one of her TikTok
moves, but I think health
and safety got involved
'cause I was nearly...
I pulled my back out so...
- [Kelly] I hear that you actually grew up
going to clubs a lot, like
Techno? Did you like Tech?
- I did that, yeah, yeah.
How did that get out? But, yes I do.
- I just wanna see you dancing in a club.
That's my Dr. Strange dancing
in the club, that's my...
- That's the only way
- My new goal.
- You will see me dancing,
is probably is if I'm in a club dancing.
- How do you dance to Techno?
- Like I said, that's the only way
you're gonna see me dancing to Techno
is if I'm in a club.
- [Kelly] Have you ever
been country dancing?
- I have.
- You have?
- Yeah.
- Like line dancing?
- [Benedict] Yeah.
- [Elizabeth] What?
- At the Madonna Inn.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Ohh.
- I was coming from the beach so...
- You were like, I'm gonna give you
a geographical location, girl.
(all laugh)
I love that.
It's a good time, just saying.
- It was great fun.
We just turned out for a road stop,
and it was a long drive back from Big Sur,
which was where I was coming from,
and I'd always wanted to
go into the inn, properly.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- There was a line dance going on.
I thought, great, I have an
old fashion, I wasn't driving.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- And then...
(Benedict laughs)
I got busy. Yeah.
- [Kelly] I got bu... I got busy.
- [Elizabeth] I love the dancing trail.
- I love it, he said I got
busy, I'm stealing that.
- We wanna see this now, don't we?
- I know, I'm like, I
need to see the video.
- I just want the people
in this Inn going,
Is that Doctor Strange?
(guests laugh)
They were just watching you.
I would have been so excited.